what are feminine traits nurturing soft
caring playful empathetic compassionate
vulnerable so when we're talking about
healing like all the things you guys
listed none of them got you to that like
tastes like getting rid of people for
six months doesn't make you more
nurturing soft caring playful empathetic
going on a trip doesn't make you more
compassionate and vulnerable yeah due to
opposites yeah it does the opposite
in addition to no relationship but
that's exactly my point that's the point
like let's say you feel more confident
yeah but it's to a point where like you
know certain that you're more masculine
yeah that's made you a more confident
and better person in yourself but as a
partner he might not be looking for that
woman who's too loud all that too in his
face it's again because we become the
men we want to marry because we like
confident men they don't their guys
aren't into confident women they're into
shy women that are like reserves
in any Kingdom
doesn't mean you're better I think it
says the latter because when I go
through spiritual experiences Etc I
become way more tolerant because now
it's less about me and it's more about
like I see why you did that I see I
understand this so I can handle this
better so we don't have to argue we have
to fight I get it
um so if you come out of a so-called
spiritual experience and you're actually
less tolerant of everyone around you
that gives it that's again lends more
Credence to the idea of like it's more
of a narcissistic ritual it's more like
but that wasn't what I was talking about
the spiritual the cutting off thing had
nothing to do with spirituality at all
it was more about
clean like dealing with the noise that
was in my head it had nothing to do with
like spiritual stuff that was for me but
the whole the whole spiritual thing is I
think you know often serve as a really
good way to not be accountable because
spiritualism is relative like you could
make a lot of cases and say you know
listen to Jada Pinkett Smith right she
can validate hanging with August all day
yeah
okay she might not be a good example but
they're common and so this is this is
common whenever I hear to girls talk
about like spiritual experiences I'm
like just say you're three or four no
I just and I'm not I don't know you so I
I'm not saying you are I'm just saying
this is I've talked to so many people in
the last six months that these are like
patterns yeah I don't know like people
that I know that are spiritual I don't
know tons but they all seem to have some
sort of level head and I know what you
mean by you're saying that people could
just say oh well I'm spiritual and da da
and they can push that onto that but
there are there are people sorry there
are people who are not like that there
are people I get what you're saying
about being tolerable and more tolerant
but sometimes that comes with stepping
away from the noise realizing okay what
can I do what am I sure of what can I
give what can I take back what can I
keep from us what can I give it's not
just about ego but I get what you're
saying as well it's a give and take it's
a balance of both
if that makes any sense you look very
confused
I understood what you said okay
do you have are you sure
I can see a butt
um yeah I understand that but to me it
just sounded like I need to be right it
kind of It kind of just sounded like
um
you know trying to get out the fact that
spiritual practice breeds tolerance and
love more so than anything else and it
minimizes self and so if that
understanding if you say talk about that
story I hate to be personal to me most
of the key points of that that your
story your spiritual journey or healing
one it didn't make you more loving it
didn't make you you just talk about
yourself a lot you said you know Mimi
you know that kind of thing it didn't
make you more tolerant
that other experience was something else
but I think spiritual connects to
everything like we have a pattern you
can see it in our life so your healing
Journey isn't disassociated from that
action whether it was before or after
you're saying everything is
interconnected it's interconnected and
so you know yes you need you need time
alone but
um cutting people off again it even
sounds like a bit of a plan to focus on
the right things basically yeah it even
sounds like a power play like you never
hear someone appear saying I caught
people off what do you think I meant by
cutting people off I for me it was just
them not having access or availability
every single day throughout the day
sorry but when you when you hear that
that doesn't sound feminine nurturing or
soft but I am feminine nurturing I don't
think well you don't I'm saying you
don't come across that way because of
the words that you say but that's
because I'm able to articulate I'm I'm
implicit so and I don't think it's a bad
thing for me to say I'm intelligent but
if I'm in a man's presence or if I'm
with someone who I'm romantically
connected with my air my aura and how I
I am is very different so if we ask your
access would they agree yeah okay and
they what my ex watches this show so
hopefully he's watching any comments
surely it's other people's like that's
like okay it's kind of like if a man
said I'm super masculine but only when
I'm around women but so so so like
that's like if a guy said like it sounds
like crazy because like if a guy if a
guy comes in he acts super like feminine
right and he's like hey like hey girls
then he's like look it I am super
masculine but only when I'm around
Victoria's Secret models I get what
you're saying but I'm in a situation
right now where I have to think and I
have to articulate myself so therefore
maybe do you know what maybe that's my
Alpha side I don't know maybe that is my
Alpha side I've run a business so I have
that Alpha streak but at the same time
I've been with men who are quite Alpha
and they're like they've pointed certain
things out to me so I've learned not
only through what I've seen at home with
my mom and my dad but I've also learned
through those men and through my own
journey to be more feminine so I I'll be
about loving energy it's about patience
it's about it's about all these kind of
compromise and everything you say seems
to be more around
you know you you kind of you know
realizing power in some way so
you know you say you're intelligent and
you're you've had a business and you cut
people off and no but you're now
listening your aura is like different in
other people it's all a lot of
affirmations and words you you tend to
you you know what to say but feminism
isn't like I guess yeah it's a way of
being yeah like it's loving it like you
can tell you can tell when someone's
feminine but no one can tell me they're
feminine that doesn't mean anything for
everyone who knows me who experiences me
will tell you otherwise
yeah but I'm saying like if if everyone
in the room is saying one thing you
don't think that
but this is the first time I've been
interviewing yeah yeah yeah so yeah but
you know I guess that again proved your
point of me not listening yeah avoid bus
and try and you know yeah I know even
just that it was also you basic that's
what I'm saying it was my whole point of
like he's basically saying that all your
points is more like it's like a bit
self-centered but it's less as like me
being a partner so that's what I'm
saying it's like you being
all these qualities
is not necessarily like appealing to
like a man or to a relationship but I
get what you mean in terms of saying
it's better to you but that's the
overall like everyone disagreeing with
you I feel like they're basically saying
it's like but to a man or to like a
relationship yeah it's not bringing much
value and you're absolutely right
because you asked me in the beginning
what is my status and I said it's very
weird and it's very complicated right
now I don't feel like I'm in the best
space to be in a relationship because
remember I just said six months
everything was off
I know that I'm still not ready fully I
know what it feels like to be vulnerable
I know it feels like to be
come to compromise I know it feels like
to listen and all of that I do not feel
like right now right now I just feel
like I have to just focus on me and
everyone's journey is different everyone
gets to a specific place in their life
and I think as women we are so
conditioned to be like you must give you
must be loving you must be nurturers
which is what we are naturally by birth
or whatever but I think it's also part
of self-preservation if my cup is empty
I can't pour
I need I need something for me too if I
mothers they say what do they usually
say my mom usually has time for herself
every Sunday where she focuses on her
and during the rest of the week she's
able to pour into everybody in the
household she I don't think she'll be
able to do that if she didn't take time
for her so would you say you're still
healing
there's that word again
I need to Define that today man recovery
yeah
so technically it's not linear right